my buddy one time got a uh the first bj
in our area right i mean people were
[ __ ] fired up wait what is that we're
talking some your area seventh grade
seventh grade yeah yeah yeah that was
around the same time so he got bj'ed up
and everybody was [ __ ] you could hear
people cheering in the damn distance it
was like you know you could hear his
ancestors
23 men was lightened up yeah you could
see i mean betsy ross just put another
star on the flag you know like
people were excited right yes so then it
the story came out that people started
hearing about it yeah right and then the
gal's parents heard about it
so then the gal and her parents went
over the parents called my buddy's
parents oh my god and this poor girl
because they were real pretty religious
and so they said well we're going to
come over here and talk about this if
people's bj and and if our child's bj
and we're going to come over there and
talk about it
so they drove over and my buddy was like
dude i i remember talking him on the
phone before he's like i have to go sit
in there oh my gosh and they want us to
tell them everything that happened no
here's the crazy part
here's the craziest part
they made them sh not like physically
show them like with their sexual parts
but like okay show us how you were
show us how you were so then the gal is
because my buddy let me put the phone on
and let it be just under the table in
there and when the meeting was going on
my god
so because i think the parents wanted to
make sure that everything was and there
was nothing like force that happened
okay so they're having it basically
reenactment right then here's the crazy
part
they send the kids out of the room so
that they can talk about it
and i don't remember exactly but i swear
my buddy give him another one
while they were talking about it man
that's when you gotta [ __ ] beat that
hammer son i mean the seventh grade i
remember the first girl that gave a book
eighth grade the first girl it was just
like it was out i
all the chicks were like oh and all the
guys were like
yeah i mean it was so titillating i mean
i wanted to know everything about it but
i was like god damn it i haven't even
kissed a boy i'm years away from kissing
a guy a friend of mine just put i
remember sobbing the first time one of
my close friends sucked a penis i cried
so hard because i knew that i would have
to do it someday
and i also knew that i lost her like we
don't have anything in common now if you
can do that it was like my friends who
rode roller coasters i wanted to so bad
but i was too scared i just couldn't do
it i and i would just sit at six flags
and sit on the bench janet's gone yeah
yep that's how i felt she's gone and i
lost her i really cried like i mourned
it because i just felt like i'm getting
left behind and i did like all my
friends got boyfriends were like hooking
up getting their [ __ ] eaten and i
just had never even kissed a boy and i
would be like just but i knew everything
i would ask every detail so by the time
i did that stuff i knew exactly what to
do
i was not i was not nervous by the time
that i got i got to the place where i
was like the librarian of it kind of it
seems like you were kind of the pro at
that point you were yeah yes i knew
everything and i didn't get my period
till super late and i was by the time i
got my period all my i knew everything
about because my friends i would ask
every detail i put in a tampon like i
was like
an old grizzled ant like it was like
i've been doing it for years and you as
a girl you don't start with tampons you
start with like pads or like toilet
paper and you're like am i dying why am
i bleeding but i was just like oh i know
what to do here because i just knew
because i had asked so many questions
and i think that's what i still have is
that like curiosity about sex like it
even though i have it and now i'm in
that world i still am just like
i just want to know every detail i just
think it's fascinating like how we get
from being clothed to unclothed and like
licking each other's privates it's just
so weird yeah oh then i remember i ended
up getting a bj one time first one
yeah
and we met out oh i remember we were
meeting in the woods it was at a party
yeah it's like let's go meet in the
woods
and louisiana has wood woods it's not i
mean there's like spiders there's like
dragons
there's like dead [ __ ] out there
probably yeah you know there's pirate
ships there's a lot in there so you meet
in the woods but we met in the woods and
it was getting damp like we were meeting
it was getting real um
muddy
so i mean i remember being oh we were
slogging and dude and then i remember it
getting even a little bit more like
almost like probably a couple inches of
water oh my god where are we meeting am
i going kind of the wrong way to me
so i'm like
you know i'm like out and damn
you know i'm almost in south carolina
you know i'm saying like i really
you know i'm in the backdrop of where
the crawdads saying you know what i'm
saying it's really like
i'm passing boats like and you don't
have phones how do you know where to
meet this girl dude i was just following
the possibility
that i was going to get a bj did it
happen i would still be walking
if the possibility had never left my
head
and so i finally we finally got to each
other and by that point i mean i had
like locus on me i had like
i was a damn ecosystem you know like i
was certainly uh i wasn't doing great
you know there was like scientists
texting me there was like oh my god you
know it was really hot it was bad
oh there was moss growing on the north
side of me like i had barely made it to
i was three years older when i got to
her when i finally got there it was
illegal
for her to give me the [ __ ]
how long it took man it was it awesome
was it like as good as you had thought
it would be
because i mean i'm guessing this girl is
like a younger like you're on the
younger side of things it's probably one
of her first two maybe you know uh maybe
she doesn't know what she's doing but
was it just so great
well by that point other kids that come
in looking for us you know oh okay by
that point by the time we finally met it
there were other kids yelling and yeah
because you were missing for hours oh it
was this crazy party
oh it was crazy there was a lantern i
remember i'm like somebody had a little
lantern out here
there was a lantern there was beagles oh
there were two beagles
you know
uh it was getting and it was getting
really really bad you know and so we had
to shut it down right okay
and then
another time
um
so then we rebooked it for a couple of
weeks later when someone else had a
party yeah you know
so
you knew it was going to be a blow job
yeah i knew it because she had maybe
done it before yeah and she was like the
one that you knew to go to for that kind
of thing but i also liked her though oh
yeah that's sweet so i really really
liked her and i think i was also there
was embarrassment because she'd done
some [ __ ]
yes you know so you thought
did you i like her but i'm afraid of
what other people will think if i like
her oh yeah cause she's [ __ ] i don't
know if she's a [ __ ] but she's done some
[ __ ] right well i was saying [ __ ]
isn't like people like i think she's and
then what does that mean and then you
can't
yeah are you one of these guys that um
if you're dating someone you don't want
to know about their history you don't
want to you kind of want to convince
yourself
uh you kind of want to be in denial of
their past even though you know like you
just don't want to know about it
i don't care anymore oh that's good
because it's like unless they were like
work uh yeah i don't think i care really
i think it's more now about what the
connection is you know yeah um
but then i remember me and this gal we
befriended somebody so we could go to
their birthday right like we kind of
like because you needed a spot right so
we ended up at this nerdy girl's
birthday right i met her at the library
i'm sure
neither of us even really knew her and
we're at the party and we're kind of
using her for her guest room oh people
are trying to like just play games and
stuff and it was water balloons and like
it was really
it was still like a b
they were real uh
there was more premature you know
and so we were trying to get a sneak off
for this bj you know when they're doing
like pin the tail on the dunk and just
things where it's like
we gotta get this
clown yeah and time was ticking it was
getting later in the day like there was
a pony there was a pony right now god oh
my god we gotta sneak off and get this
bj in somewhere around here and uh so we
snuck off behind this tree and it was
like
they don't really have a trees wide
enough to get a bj behind them where i'm
from you know without somebody seeing
somebody thin birches yeah it's a lot
more what's the thickest tree in
louisiana you think zach if you can pull
something up like that
because you can really get blown behind
one of these uh okay
you know
no yeah search only for thickest that
taxodium distectum huh
15.90 what does that mean that's girth
yeah
yeah it's about girth that's uh we're
talking meters here
i assume diameter
[Music]
so
well i guess these people couldn't
afford one of those right so because
that's really wide enough almost
especially at that age in california you
got the redwoods you can [ __ ] have an
orgy behind one of those
[Laughter]
oh dude you can build a car max behind
one of them
but anyway i couldn't and the and the
kid's mom came over oh [ __ ] and was like
y'all are blow job and then i was like
i'm not you know and
then the girl felt bad when i said i'm
not oh and uh and then i felt bad
because i wasn't like it was her idea no
i wasn't she was doing it you know oh
right they're [ __ ] they're blow
topping i'm not i'm just standing here
she came up yeah she came i was just
trying to get some air
no not that she came up like my yeah
like
[Laughter]
like my penis was just wandering around
the air okay wait a second you can't get
you said when was your first complete
like you're getting man well so then we
got busted and that was a bad issue
and then um
probably about
i think it was a couple years later
a girl gave me a hand job into a um
small waterway
and uh
like a stream everything is outdoors
for you guys
yeah well like that yeah i think of the
people i knew didn't have big indoors
yeah so it was like if there's not a lot
of room indoors you gotta so into a
small waterway you were like looking
over a small bobbling brook
no it was bit it was larger than that i
mean you could catch something out of it
all right
and
so you got a hand job out of that into
the stream into the street yes he goes
back so scared you know yeah that scared
me what's because i would never be able
to get that semen back first no really
there was something about it hadn't you
ejaculated before and felt the same way
or did you try to put it back in then
like
well my armor we jerked off one time and
my dad made us bury it out in the yard
no way what
yeah wait he caught you jerking off
and he's bury your semen
in the backyard
so you in your hand not even in the back
it was in the side yard
wait
that is
why why
i don't know he said that's god's and
that's where it goes oh my god
theo
pretty cool that's crazy
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one